what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with dark ages so here's the
thing following basically the last issue
that we did and the death of nick fury
at this point all the heroes essentially
land on the shores of portugal right
they are finally in europe and as soon
as they're there they're met by the
arrival of deadpool
now of course deadpool survived all this
which you would kind of expect from
deadpool one because of the fact that
he's just got an insane healing factor
and two deadpool has a power of the plot
he can survive virtually anything so one
of the things that he does in true
deadpool fashion is of course he greets
everybody says hey welcome to europe and
then ask the question before i bring out
my standard hats and accents i just want
to gauge how everybody feels about
cultural stereotypes
now here's the thing i have never the
only place i've traveled to abroad is
london right so outside of like mocking
people with london accents which i
didn't do i don't really know how you do
like cultural stereotypes with london i
can say unequivocally they've got tea on
lockdown but i imagine going to france
and just being like
we
fancy people like that's probably going
to piss off people in france
i can't imagine why i wouldn't but uh
nonetheless right it's just one of those
little deadpool things where he just
kind of hangs out and does his own
little thing but then ultimately he's
basically told that like nick fury's
died and this is one of those
sentimental moments from deadpool that
you don't normally see where he's just
kind of like damn all right you know
like he was one of the good guys you
know where deadpool is kind of like okay
you know and then like literally stands
in line with everybody else and
basically pays his respects to nick fury
now one of the things to understand
about this this is one of the cool
things to understand about deadpool nine
times out of ten deadpool's written as a
goofy character there have been precious
few stories after the joe kelly and ed
mcginnis era really where deadpool was
written in a serious way but that has
happened before and one of the things
that was really a big focus in that era
and really kind of carried on into
future stories is the level of respect
deadpool has for people sometimes and
nick fury's one of those guys where even
though deadpool is zany and goofy and
kinda silly he still respects nick fury
quite a lot just because of all the
things that nick fury's done over the
course of his life the work that he's
put in and the fact that even though
some of the things he did were a bit
questionable he was always one of the
good guys he was usually looking out for
the superhero community and so deadpool
can respect that from there we switch
over to paris right now remember
apocalypse kind of has this big plot
that he's that he's really engaging in
in terms of how it is that he intends to
conquer everything and so having this
conversation with tony stark the
question is asked here is can
apocalypse's plan come to fruition and
where tony's like you know i like i
understand what is it you want but i
need to see the size of the problem that
we're talking about here and so this is
when apocalypse tells kilgrave to come
with himself and tony stark as they go
down into the core of the earth now
kilgrave doesn't necessarily want to do
that and here's the thing that i do want
to address here so for the people who
are unfamiliar with zebedee kilgrave
he's just a guy who controls the
controls like the minds of other people
right makes them do things that they
don't want to necessarily do kilgray's
power is more nuanced than that it's not
really mind control so much as
pheromones but one of the things that's
been established over the years in
marvel comics is that if a person's
fortitude like if they are resilient
enough or they have enough just gumption
they can actually overcome kilgrave an
apocalypse certainly fits that mold
apocalypse is not a guy that kilgrave
would be able to overcome it just
wouldn't work that way i would go as far
as to say there was probably a time when
he tried right when he tried to overtake
apocalypse and it simply just didn't
work i would love to see that moment
just in marvel comics when kilgrave
tries to ensnare apocalypse and well
apocalypse will probably kill him you
know just just for inconveniencing him
if anything else but nonetheless having
killgrave at his side here as you guys
know allows kilgrave to control
virtually everyone here so in that
instance kilgray's a huge asset the
bigger question that you have to ask
here is how does it work with somebody
like tony stark well the caveat that tom
taylor seems to be going with here is
that in effect kilgrave snuck up on tony
stark so even if you have resilience
kilgrave can sneak up on you and
overtake you which then begs the
question how does it work with
apocalypse but there's all kinds of
questions with this story right like how
can peter parker keep us abreast on
circumstances that he wasn't a part of
right how could he like narrate
circumstances that he was not involved
in
he wasn't there but there's all kinds of
things about this story that are a
little wonky but you know how it is with
comics we just take it with a grain of
salt just go with it but the thing about
this is that that tony stark of course
ends up going to the core of the earth
along with apocalypse and kilgrave and
basically everybody else reed richards
and all them and of course we're
ultimately met with the arrival of the
unmaker of course again this being that
is a living machine that in turn has
been de-powered with the opening of this
portal by stephen strange that amidst
this constant emp but with siemens
strange being dead there's no way to
close the portal so as long as this
portal stays open both the earth and the
unmaker will basically have no method of
functionality whatsoever on a
technological sense but if they close
this portal then the unmaker will wake
back up again right it'll just
reactivate the earth will get
electricity back but it won't make any
difference because everything you would
need electricity for will be destroyed
when the earth was annihilated in the
first place and so one of the cool
things this is one of the little details
that i like about how tom taylor wrote
this obviously the story itself is wrote
written in a bit of a rush but one of
the things that i love about how tom
taylor handled this is as they're
passing the body of doctor strange
they're told do not touch the body of
strange right he may be dead but his
magical wards are still in place and god
only knows what it's going to do to you
but that's when they ultimately get to
the portal and the the theory that reed
richards has is that on the other side
of this portal is basically a neutron
star that gives off a constant
electromagnetic pulse and the response
to tony stark is well i mean that that's
a good working theory i mean we won't
really know until we if we unless we
decide to go through the portal but if
we do we'd literally have to contend
with the gravitational pull of a neutron
star to give you guys perspective here
and and i'm not going to swear by this
number i want to say i heard it in the
documentary somewhere i don't know if
that's if it's really true but the
gravitational pull of a neutron star is
so extreme that if you were to somehow
be able to put a ladder on the surface
of a neutron star and climb up to the
top of the ladder assuming it was like
20 feet that like the gravitational pull
at your feet would be astronomical
compared to the gravitational pull of
your head that is about as close as you
get to the gravitational pull of a black
hole again not going to swear by that
and i assume somebody out there in the
comments section who's more in tune with
that aspect of physics can probably give
us a better answer than i could but the
thing about this is it's still a cool
little thing right it's basically the
source of where all this comes from now
that would also have to assume that this
may very well be a dimension that houses
nothing but that neutron star because i
don't really know if life could exist in
the presence of a neutron star because
it would literally pull in everything
around it
you know you would assume life wouldn't
necessarily even have the ability to
exist either that or life would exist as
a ring around this neutron star but
whatever the case happens to be that's
the source of the problem and so
ultimately what apocalypse reveals here
is that he has studied the unmaker for
years right he says i've touched every
part of its sleeping mind to inhabit it
to take control of a power beyond that
of even a celestial or a god he says i
would not need long minutes perhaps an
hour and so that's where they're kind of
like damn to contain the power of a
neutron star for an hour that would be
kind of nuts but that's the goal of
apocalypse the goal of apocalypse is to
basically reactivate the unmaker and
then seize control of it for himself and
then travel around now this is not
arbitrary i mean it's it is kind of to a
degree but not necessarily what tom
taylor is doing is actually pulling on
some strings that are really tied to
aspects of apocalypse's history that are
really more in line with antiquity than
anything else right just old school
stuff so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with apocalypse the way this
worked is that for the longest time he
was just an external and even now
whether or not he's an external is up
for debate a lot of people argue whether
or not it's actually true but regardless
he is by all standards of measurement
immortal and he could alter his size to
a degree but when he came across
celestial technology for the first time
he didn't know how to utilize it he
couldn't access it because the truth is
that he was primitive in comparison to
celestial technology what ended up
happening is cable came from the future
fought apocalypse and then some of
cable's techno-organic virus basically
uh infected apocalypse and when that
happened it allowed him to access the
celestial technology what ended up
happening and i want to say it was
irishm the judge who appeared to
appear to apocalypse but essentially a
bargain was struck and this wasn't
something that we learned until after
the events of house of m with the blood
of apocalypse storyline but we ended up
finding out that basically the the
nature of this deal is that the
celestials would allow apocalypse to use
their power for quote-unquote future
payments at a later date basically it
was a way for marvel to just kind of
craft a story where they could remove
apocalypse from the equation for the
marvel landscape for however long they
needed until they wanted to bring him
back but regardless of the situation the
the whole idea here is apocalypse and
celestial technology run hand in hand in
that way the way it was explained in
that story in the blood of apocalypse
story is the reason why he's always
tried to attain so much power is to
ensure that when the time comes that the
celestials basically intend to take him
away that he could actually challenge
and defeat them and so he wouldn't have
to worry about being snatched up and
tortured killed whatever it is that they
were going to do to him experiment on
him or what have you and so the results
of this is that tom taylor is largely
pulling on those strings again they are
they're archaic strings they're old
strings but they're strings that are
still there nonetheless and so what this
really shows is that by and large the
history of apocalypse is still intact in
this alternate reality story in terms of
his schemes his motivations his
mechanisms and why he's doing what he's
doing i mean we can also surmise that
like using the power of the unmaker he
would bring his social darwinism to the
universe right and just rule the
entirety of the universe but at the end
of the day the stance of iron man is
it's not really possible but i'm always
up for a challenge and so at that point
what we do is we basically switch back
over to probably one of the best moments
in the story which is kind of hilarious
where dr doom gives peter parker just
this backhanded compliment right where
peter's pissed off at his daughter mae
for basically sneaking aboard stowing
away and he's like they can't come with
us and then deadpool's kind of like i
mean really dude because you know great
responsibility is kind of like your
whole thing and it'd be pretty
irresponsible to leave your kid in a
refugee camp
so i absolutely love that line of logic
from deadpool because he's not wrong
there's nothing about what he's saying
that's incorrect here so i absolutely
love it at the same time storm's not
going back so there's no real way for
the kids to go anywhere right storm's
not going back because he's just like
you're gonna need everybody on hand
right i mean if you're facing off
against apocalypse man it's gonna take a
little more than like spider-sense to
overcome this guy right like you're
gonna need everybody on deck for this
and so it's kind of funny because peter
parker chastises may tells you that he's
disappointed and then dr dooms like if
mae had not sounded the alarm the ghost
raiders attack may have been fatal to
all of us and he says i myself am unused
to being disobeyed and it's clear she
needs a firmer hand from a stronger
patriarch but she saved us we would all
be dead if it had not been for your
daughter's insolence
now here's the thing here's the thing
ask anybody who's been reading marvel
comics for any measure of time this is
kind of a compliment from doctor doom
right i mean it's backhanded but it's
kind of a con it's as close as you're
going to get to dr doom being like you
know what peter your daughter really
saved our life don't be too hard on her
i mean that's basically what he's saying
but he's saying it in like a doctor doom
way it's one of those doctor doom things
right just kind of the way the doctor
doom addresses things
and so ultimately you know you have
jessica jones who chips in and is like
look i know it's going to sound crazy
peter i know you're not going to want to
hear it but at the end of the day
they really are better off with us right
i mean we'll keep them protected we'll
give our lives to make sure they're safe
but like they really are better off with
us plus your daughter's got powers and
that could probably come in handy
somewhere along the line and so
ultimately deadpool's like yeah
family road trip to the heart of
darkness and so he gets like a dead
mobile right now i don't know if
deadpool has ever had a dead mobile it's
basically a batmobile but for deadpool
uh well technically it's a it's a dead
pool bus but you understand the point
right it's cool like i absolutely love
this idea of deadpool getting like his
own mode of transportation i think it's
amazing and i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i don't know if this appears in
other deadpool comics but if it doesn't
it needs to appear more often i think
it'd be hilarious if like in the new
deadpool movie right deadpool 3 that
like some kind of crazy thing pops off
you know or like when he first appears
in the mcu and you just hear like this
bus horn pull up and deadpool just like
he rolls up in a bus right like the dead
mobile and it's like what's going on
guys like it's like it takes like two
minutes right for him to like shut
everything down turn it off open the
door and then get out
it's just like this two-minute ordeal of
like deadpool getting out of his vehicle
i feel like it'd be hilarious right it's
like the most deadpool thing ever but at
the end of the day of course they all
end up basically racing off to europe
now the thing about this or at least in
paris anyway the thing about this is
that from portugal to paris takes a
little more than just a bus trip right
takes a little more than like a few
hours and so ultimately they end up just
kind of sitting aside and resting for a
period of time and basically you get
this realization from gabby that like
someone's tracking them right there's a
scent they're picking up on that's not
supposed to be there and and as it's
described it smells like like rotted
meat right like it's just it's bitter
it's rotten it's nasty and it's like we
don't know exactly what this is but
whatever it is is hunting for us and so
at that point like literally they're in
europe right like the heart of the
vampire empire and so at that point uh
blades like let's go hunting and so as
these go scoping around seemingly the
attacker comes from out of nowhere only
for us to find out it's basically the
apocalypse symbiote now the apocalypse
simulates mind-blowing the nature of
gabby is that the nanites in her body
prevent her from feeling pain which is
true and as a result of that she's never
really felt pain before in her life but
being impaled like this she feels the
full sensation of what it means to her
she's feeling pain for the very first
time and of course screams out exactly
the way that you would expect at that
point dr doom fires up right it's just
like it's like just this amazing shot
which to be honest man i kind of want
this with no speech bubbles so i can
frame it because i feel like it would it
would just be amazing but he's literally
like stay together stay with the fire
right because seemingly like doctor doom
has kind of picked up on what's going on
to a degree because one of the things
that peter and them say is like i mean
we don't pick up anything like we don't
detect anything which right off the bat
doctor dude just kind of like okay so
that means symbiotes right that means
whatever's hunting us it can be detected
by lowerca which means it's there and if
it was a vampire peter parker would
detect it if it was anything other than
something that was symbiote-based peter
parker would protect it hence the logic
stay with the fire because as we know
symbiotes are weak to fire now at that
point we end up finding out that what's
gone on here is the venom symbiote and
the carnage symbiote have actually
merged together onto a singular host now
of course the first thing and this is
really just an assassination mission is
what this really is the first thing to
do here is take out moon girl right like
eliminate her because she's basically
the smartest person in the group of
course devil dinosaur jumps in the way
don't worry guys devil dinosaur doesn't
die
right devil dinosaur is like a dog for
us right like we don't care what happens
to the people as long as nothing happens
to the dog we are incensed
this is one of those crazy things but of
course devil dinosaur survives right
devil dinosaur makes it basically chews
up the symbiote spits them out simeon of
course doesn't die but that leads to
peter parker stepping in now of course
deadpool makes this hilarious mark a
remark about how peter parker's uh how
his his web shooters are changed now uh
because basically they they go by swap
instead of thwip which of course is
based on the new technology he uses uh
basically a furnace-based system to
power his uh his web shooters than
anything else but again like they're
literally surrounded by basically a
carnage and venom symbiote merger onto a
single host here's the thing guys venom
is enough for pretty much any one of
these guys and that's on a bad day right
you throw in venom on a good day no he'd
overpower virtually everybody here then
you add carnage into the mix basically
there'd be no real chance anybody here
could defeat this guy but that's when
you get pepper potts stepping in with
the iron man suit now one of the things
to remember because of the fact that all
electricity across the world has been
taken down stark tech as it
traditionally exists is basically out
the window this new iron man suit that's
being used by pepper potts which is
really just kind of a modified uh
hulkbuster suit that is actually a
walking furnace right it's really what
it is like it's literally like the iron
furnace we could call it that
what do you guys think we should call
you know what you guys name it what do
you think that we should call this iron
man suit right like would you call it
like the iron furnace i don't know what
do you guys think that we should call
this thing but ultimately because of the
fact that it's literally powered by fire
the pepper steps in and just literally
blasts the symbiote off of his host and
then of course that leads to uh leads to
storm jumping in and then using the
power of thunder and lightning to
basically destroy the symbiotes in their
entirety so now the venom and the
carnage symbiotes are totally
annihilated which begs the question
who's the host of the venom symbiont
right who's the host like who which what
person has been ensnared by both of
these symbiotes and forced to operate as
a host the answer to that question is
that it's miles morales i bet you
thought i was going to leave you on a
cliffhanger didn't you like the answer
to that question we'll find out next
video no the answer is that it's miles
morales right now we don't know how that
happened and we will actually find out
later but what what miles says is
because remember whenever a person is
ensnared by the purple man and we're
assuming that miles was that whenever
that happens even if that wasn't the
case miles was still in there albeit
with the venom and the carnage symbiote
you're really kind of being the ones
running the show that he remembers
everything that happened and he's like i
know exactly how apocalypse is going to
end the world and what this does is it's
going to take this timetable that the
superheroes have and it's going to speed
it up like that they're going to have
virtually no time at all but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace